hey we're uh just showing you we saw a
few little flakes on our
strat cam looking out over the valley uh
just a few moments ago
so uh just to just reinforce the idea
that we got a lot of cold air aloft
and that we might see kind of an icy mix
of some rain
maybe a little hail again and i wanted
to show you this live camera
check this out do you see the layers
it's like a frosted cake
across the mountains this morning
absolutely beautiful this is looking to
the north now
this is actually the sheep mountains off
to the west the spring mountains to the
north
are the sheep mountains it is so pretty
out there but it's wet too we're getting
rain this morning
and it is cold out on the west side to
the south valley lots of upper 30s in
the middle of town
we've been close to 30s very close and
teens up on the mountain
six plus inches of snow up at lee canyon
and then we've been getting kind of a
snowy mix all around the edges of the
valleys in the north
to the west side a very healthy rain
totals thank goodness over a third of an
inch of rain officially
just helping us catch up but we're still
really behind and look at the mccullough
range
some of those rain totals over half an
inch of rain in the last 24 hours lots
of neighborhoods been picking up some
nice rainfall
and we're looking to get more today so
this low pressure system
is a little bit band of rain and snow
that's just been centered right on top
of us
since last night you can see the snow
south of the valley in southern clark
county this morning
and low snow levels because of the
colder air
but we have winter weather advisories
that are in place for the higher
elevations we're getting some rain now
in
west valley neighborhoods the winter
weather advisory
for a lincoln county clark county
mountains and even up into utah
and maybe another four to eight inches
above 6 000 feet
in our local mountains so please be
careful if you don't have the right
kind of vehicles to get up in the
mountains might avoid it for today
55 maybe chance of showers and
thunderstorms
as the system works its way through
slowly today
and maybe not even freezing up there on
the mountain but we'll say 32 probably
stay in the 20s really
scattered showers all the way through
tonight isolated thunderstorms
we could even see more of that it's
called grapple it's really
icy snow did you get some of that in
your neighborhood yesterday a lot of
west valley neighborhoods
out towards summerlin near the spring
mountains we're getting this
and you can hear it most of the time you
don't hear snow
so you know this is different because
it's got an icy component to it
but it was accumulating on the lawns and
you could see it in the parking lots as
it was falling
and mountain's edge i want to thank b.j
she sent a little video
of actual little hail all right so after
today we're going to get into some nice
sunny conditions
71 as we spring forward in a daylight
saving time this weekend
next week lots of 70s even mid 70's
later in the week